cómo afectan estas complicaciones a
bolsonaro de cara a las elecciones de
para estar de valentina evidentemente el
primer la primera semana activa del año
con bolsonaro hospitalizado es la
noticia que reverbera en todos los
medios de comunicación y también aquí en
brasilia en los 22 políticos del
presidente como usted decía el inicio ha
sido hospitalizado y luego de otras
cuatro intervenciones quirúrgicas
sufridas luego de un atentado del que
fue víctima en 2018 cuando era candidato
presidencial en la zona abdominal un
atentado por el cual él debió de hacer
campaña electoral y finalmente fue
electo las circunstancias actuales no se
sabe si derivarán en una cirugía como
dio a entender el presidente o como su
médico dijo tal vez pudiera evitarse
aclaramos que bolsonaro se encuentra en
san paulo a donde arribó ya la madrugada
procedente de las playas del sur del
país y su médico se encuentra en bahamas
todavía no arribo
sao paulo para hacer un análisis del
paciente de 66 años que se encontraba
con una sonda e internado ya en un
hospital en una clínica privada de la
capital paulista bueno y el mandatario
ha recibido fuertes críticas entre otras
cosas por su manejo de la pandemia qué
posibilidades reales hay de que logre
una reelección
son dos respuestas de difícil
diagnóstico en este momento y las
críticas que ha sufrido bolsonaro por su
actitud frente a las pandemias se
renovaron este primero dinero cuando en
un discurso obligatorio en cadena de
radio y televisión criticó la vacunación
y también recomendó o dio a entender que
no era recomendable que fueran vacunados
los niños de entre 5 y 11 años de edad
desde primera hora desde que comenzó la
pandemia en brasil brasil es uno de los
países con más víctimas fatales en el
mundo 619.000 bolsonaro se declaró en
contra de la vacunación el mismo no se
ha vacunado e inclusive en dos visitas
el año pasado una a nueva york y otra a
roma' algunos dignatarios evitaron darle
la mano por su condición de persona no
vacunada respecto de las elecciones el
tiene por el momento el 22 por ciento de
intenciones de voto contra el 48% del
candidato de momento favorito luiz
inácio lula da silva